you dated black guys loved black guys
yeah yeah
i did i did but for me dark meat on the
side white keeps me mean and lean you
know that's why
i married a white man that's what i like
what can i break it's okay i got control
so we're meet now not only are we i
we're the worst form and i could never
ever say some [ __ ] so
atrocious on tv about women
and you know what i don't want to have
that right
i'm not going to try to fight to have
that right i'm not going to try to have
the
it should be actually no i don't want
that i don't want that
that double standard y'all can keep but
wow
oddly enough though dark meat has more
nutrients so
just a little side effect but i'm not
even trying to go there that was 12
seconds in the video
and i can't even keep on going with that
[ __ ] but here's what's interesting
remember when we did that video about
like women
oh it's a preference i like what i like
and i'm like yeah you like what you like
but where does it come from and some
people like even this girl if you asked
her what her preference was she would
have been like oh i like everything i
don't have any preferences
but oftentimes when people have their
hierarchy of who is superior inferior
even though they're not conscious of it
in some of their commentary
you see the way she elevated white meat
versus dark meat do you think what i'm
saying
but again a lot of stuff that is
prejudicial happens below the surface
it happens in her subconscious it
happens in her split-second decisions
the irony of this is that she she made
this comment she's married to a white
white man
she's now married to jeezy she's not
married they're going out
once that white meat discarded her she
went back to her side dish
let's watch wow what do you mean
darkness
i'm saying like i like i really do think
black men are attractive i do like
that's my
what do you mean dark meat on the side
that means honey
that's i you know what that means wait
what are you reading it at i know
how did you say it i'm just saying it
like
i went like when i think about men i
dark men i do you'd like your main man
to be white and
the young
that's exactly what you said you can't
no no nobody now
you can't backtrack once they explain it
to you oh
you got you slipping oh
oh i'm better now yeah
i'm glad they reacted i'm glad they said
something they're like
that's not that's not what i said that's
not oh [ __ ]
yeah what girl that's exactly what the
hell you said
oh people like it's a preference apple
okay
imagine if you're like i want my
business partner you know i mean like my
employees can be black but my equal
business partner
only a white man wouldn't that sound
weird because you know
black is nice but white keeps me leaning
means
i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
it doesn't matter leaving me mean and
lean it doesn't matter
fetishes versus preferences
what is the difference well the fetish
is actually
something that uh you need to have in
order to get
sexual gratification or satisfaction
sure you need to have that sure
and a preference is just something
that's going to help you initiate a
first contact
you're not going to need to have that to
have full gratification but in regards
to dating when we're talking about
fascists we're talking about
specifically racialized fetishes and
they have a little bit of a different
connotation
it really comes down to the idea that if
you racially fetishize someone
we define it as you having a heightened
sense of attraction towards someone
based off of stereotypes and you go
towards the point of both
demonizing the person and idolizing them
so for example
some people want to date asian women
because asian women are inherently
submissive
that's what they feel like and so on one
hand you're basically erasing their
personality
by saying you're reducing them to this
long-standing
stereotype and on the other you're also
idolizing them because it meets your
fantasy
so that's what it means to racially
fetishize someone now
what's the difference between that and
any other kind of preference like abba
you know you said it's fine for women to
have a high preference
why can't they have a race preference
you having a race preference is not a
problem
and you want to have every preference or
any kind of fetish is not an issue to me
but i do think it's important for people
to understand that distinction because
they're not the same
and so in the same token why you're
attracted to certain things
also matters you have to understand that
attraction and preferences
aren't immutable they're not these
things that stay constant forever
they evolve with time i mean even
cultural norms of what we consider
attractive have evolved over the last 30
years
i remember when 30 years ago having a
fat ass was a bad thing
and having a booty shaped like a cd case
was the best
and i was always into fat ass i gotta
admit but you know what i'm talking
about that's cause because
women were vomiting trying to lose their
booty i know and i was like why are you
trying to lose that i'm trying to look
like pamela anderson i'm like well
that's
nothing dolly
so then you see the difference today
people everyone wants one so what
happened are they just preferences or
are they
informed by the culture around us i.e
the rise of hip-hop
led to our obsession with big booty
they used to make fun of big lips and
now look at them i'm pretty sure like in
the next 10 years
the next thing is going to be big noses
bruh these things are not immutable even
for me
personally i had a point in my life
where i was like blonde women
ew and it never dawned on me why i felt
that way about blonde hair specifically
and it just
later on i began to deconstruct stuff
i'm like oh i felt that way
because i associated blonde hair with
extreme snobbiness
and so i had a visceral reaction every
time i saw a blonde woman where i wanted
to recoil
right and so as i deconstructed that i
became open to dating blonde women
these things change over time and so you
sit there and you're like i would never
ever want to date this group okay
there's nothing wrong with that
but also ask yourself why do i feel that
way and so if we know that these things
are informed by our society
when you sit there and you say i want
asian women that's okay there's nothing
wrong with
that but if you're not from asia and if
you don't really have much contact with
asians and you have this kind of
obsession with them
where does it come from that's the only
conversation i want us to start
people are going to be like oh yeah well
abba
that one was so stupid to me some things
are mutable not everything
my height is not changeable it's
immutable my size
is mutable i can gain weight i can
broaden my shoulders it's not because
some aspects can change with your
physique
that all aspects can change the same way
it's not because some aspects of what
you're attracted to
can change that all aspects can change
that's huge
right these conversations are nuanced
and it requires us to take time to
reflect
and then people always say too like yeah
well with why people want to preserve
their class i'm like yo if you want to
preserve yourself
i don't care go go ahead i don't care
there's a large difference between you
saying i want to preserve my canadian or
irish heritage
and you're saying i don't want my
daughter to date a black person because
black people
are this and that do you see the
difference there's a difference there's
a new one
if you can't catch it if you can't catch
a difference
it's nuanced but it's pretty easy to
catch and there's nothing wrong with
wanting to preserve your heritage
i mean like i don't know why it is when
that when black people mention this
stuff people are like well that's racist
it's not do you know how many asian
communities engage in that south asians
you know how many african communities
engage in that latino communities
right like it's not an inherently racist
practice
that's just what i wanted to really get
into i want people to kind of think
about these things instead of just
coming up with basic answers and
i'm attracted to what i'm attracted to
i'm like yes you guys believe in the
idea of propaganda and its effect on
people to change their psyche and their
perception of things i don't see why you
don't think that your
perception of what's attractive can also
be affected because they're smarter than
that no yeah
my mind is impervious to [ __ ] imagery
people are spending all this money on
ads
and it's for nothing because it doesn't
work on my brain
imagery matters messaging matters words
matter
and they do affect the way we view the
world they affect the lens through which
we see it
the things that you listen to every day
they affect your psyche you don't think
this little things that
you're fed through your images affect
how you perceive beauty and attraction
let me ask you this if everyone if you
know what people are just attracted to
to what they're attracted to why is it
that black men date out of their race
far more than black women
why isn't it more equal why isn't even
distribution because
of perception so why do we have those
perceptions
where do they come from understanding
that is the larger conversation we want
to have
but this is not about shaming you
whatever you learn to stay into
but no one's criticizing you people
think i'm out here just like what are
you trying to think
a white woman you sell i don't give a sh
yo
i got too many bills to pay to care
about who you want to put your dink into
your dink
yeah let's see what you did there
dink have you never heard the word dink
dink no never that
no it was more of like a child's way of
saying
nah they used to say
leave your comments below tell us what
you guys think peace in a vacuum you can
look at this comment be like you know
she just slipped up or whatever
but if you understand the more
historical context of how
black sexuality has been perceived
how black men are good for the bedroom
but not a presentable
as mates in the real world how a lot of
wives
would have black side pieces from their
marriage
but would be afraid to walk with them it
all plays into a more global
look at how like black men are
appreciated for their
sexual prowess their prowess in the
bedroom but for no other qualities
and you heard what she said she said no
i like black men i think they're
attractive
but what i prefer is my husband who is
white
it's just interesting in the language
but you know these are just the
subtleties so for me
does it bother me do i get upset no i'm
upset about she's able to say it and
that's cool
i could never see you going on tv
saying what she said about women that's
what i was i had a problem with yo
do you whatever the problem is you could
never say something like that no
so egregious no no back like hey you
would have been taken
[Music]
so that's the kind of things that we see
and i'm just like okay
get it words your choice of words are
very important
because they depict something different
yeah and look a lot of people who don't
want to see this topic or don't want to
see this issue
will look for technicalities to be like
oh i'm going to disregard everything you
said
but again if you look at the nuance of
it it's very
clear never mind yeah that's pretty much
what it is
you know people have the opportunity to
grow maybe she's changed since who knows
[Music]
foreign